two members have shined down that is
here on the rich Ives insurer just
listening to get up which is track 11
for those scoring at home on attention
attention and good to see both of you
here Zach Mars and Brent Smith how are
you guys good to see you here glad to be
you got it now you were you now use
Acura are you a UT guy cuz you're from
Tennessee I'm not a Falls fan he's from
Knoxville oh okay so I'm I'm Memphis so
Memphis Tigers oh did I just step in it
right off the bat I'm sorry you're
Paxton Lynch guy I'm a Paxton Lynch guy
how about penny coming back right I've
think that was so good for the city I
think it was such a cool thing he's also
a big kind of pillar in the community
because he coach a you basketball
forever stilled up until this year yeah
obviously so it's really cool I just saw
him the other night at we have like a a
minor league kind of UFC thing like a
called v3 promotions yes he was at the
fights the other night saw song so you
you go up to Penny Hardaway and you're
like just hey how you doing no II like
I've never been over his house to dinner
we know each other's name well not yet
come on no he lives not far from me get
Zack Meyers over there gotta come over
to your house well I cause that is
pretty cool you and I would Dana white
the other day let's say it was the same
same boy now let's drop names
I don't know Dana White I just met him
that was the first time I ever met him
he's very nice though well he knows how
to promote that's for damn sure
he you could consider him the upper
class of promoting oh my god he sure is
he's pretty good at that so are you are
you an MMA prairie either one of you
guys MMA people or not really I know the
whole band as a whole will kind of watch
it when it's on especially when the
bigger fights are on right I'll watch it
um I don't it's not something to keep up
with but I definitely watch it when it's
on it I was a bigger fan of the
Mayweather and the notorious mr.
McGregor yeah when that happens you
check yeah he was following I was I was
just finally in one of those situations
where I felt like I was gonna see
history and and then what you see I mean
we saw history I mean he's undefeated
its history and another wagon yes
no but so you were you were locked in on
that I was just because I just felt like
both of those guys had the cojones to
to do it yeah you know I mean as you
watch the fight - you could see McGregor
you know still trying to kick him and
stuff like that so what would you Brent
call your what would be your McGregor
move and by that I mean where you would
step out of what your normal wheelhouse
is to perform other music what would
that be
everybody wants me to do like a country
record because I'm from Tennessee I have
the band question yeah I have the band
do a country record so that would kind
of be outside of my box so that would be
basically for you going to the octagon
into the square yeah it would a little
bit cuz I'm a fan of I I appreciate all
styles of music that's that's I
genuinely do sure but when I think of
country music I mean some of the new
school stuff I just I wouldn't gravitate
towards it I mean I think about Johnny
Cash Loretta Lynn you know Willie Nelson
still going very very strong but you
know just because I'm from Tennessee
doesn't you know necessarily mean that I
know how to sing a country song I think
you would you do I'll never say never
you know as long as I can still you know
yeah relatively
you guys are relatively young relatively
nicer so what would yours be thing Zach
if you stepped out of the uh I don't
know if I have one musically no I'm kind
of into everything okay so yeah I don't
know if I would would you well you
wouldn't do I mean you're not gonna go
and do like big band I wouldn't do that
there you go maybe like a big band
Orchestra thing is not true it don't
know if I could necessarily pull it off
well that that would be that's my
wheelhouse is that's my karaoke go to
this big Frank Sinatra straight I said
what's your song what's your karaoke
that's life that's great that's the only
one are you the chosen you got the one
no no I've got I've got here's what I've
got this is my karaoke okay go to these
guys have seen me do it so you can back
my play here okay we shine down here
okay all right Frank Sinatra that's life
okay
I'm from Staten Island so an a Yankee
fan so New York New York so how does he
how does a Memphis guy became no we
didn't have a baseball team got it
that was really one of the only teams
that was on like you know the channels
yeah so you Toria okay so you got him
while the getting was good this year too
yeah okay there's no red okay so it's a
New York New York that's life and then
also my way yeah but my my my finish to
my way and I've done this
Elvis my way or no no I'm sorry no
disrespect by my response I'm from New
York that's my response I take the
microphone Zack and I slam it down and
walk out Costanza where are we going
tonight oh god okay we could make this
happen
Zack were to make something happen you
know I've done karaoke one time in my
entire life and I've been singing my
whole life and it was in LA it was at
the Belmont on La Cienega it was the
only time I ever did karaoke in my life
I've never told this story before okay
and it was addicted to love by Robert
Palmer
as you do Goodwin you're good how many
do you have to have before you I wasn't
drinking at the time look it took a lot
of critics like to me that's like I can
you know we play we they were seen
Europe we did we were doing festivals
one hundred thousand hundred fifty
thousand people fine no nerves right
karaoke like sweating like I can't do it
we're not doing you were not in your own
yeah maybe that would be my actually my
octagon to boxing ring thing is karaoke
this karaoke ten drunk people who have
no idea who I have scares me to death
no killer yet huh yeah is that how you
got your start where they come up to you
and say you've got some talent kid yeah
my other two my other two my number four
is when it cuz I don't want to just be a
one-note gotcha
so I do Brandi you're a fine girl by
looking glass okay tell me do you know
what I know that is you're looking that
is you know Brent you know what I don't
that is extremely obscure for a karaoke
why some of that
now that can we is that on the list yeah
that is substituting glass Brandi yeah
what girl where what a karaoke bar do
you go to that has that song all of them
yeah yeah dude no yes really yes all of
them yeah it's like it's like doing like
Rosanna but it goes is it have you never
heard this breath I think
oh gosh 1970 something-or-other
and then the fifth one is it depends on
how hammered I am to be very honest with
you what's your poison Mike well geez I
don't well I have to be really hammered
to do poison my wife hates that I share
this let alone do it but if I'm really
really happy you're having a good night
I will sing I am woman by Helen Reddy
that's great we're in Santa Monica my
schedule today says the Rich Eisen show
nothing else afterwards a brandy I just
watched the first three lines so I'm off
but yachty by Nature I used to do like a
prayer forever that's a good one yeah
but that's okay I'm just saying a song
by a female I know right but when I'm
not hammered any James Taylor I like
James T I'm a big James Taylor I'm a
huge do you respect this Brent I mean
your descent yeah you do sweet baby
James man okay yeah I'm a huge day
what's your James Taylor so uh Carolina
on my mind
great song will copper line anything
like that no no no that's basically it
all right just Carolina I've got a broad
yeah I will say this as a crooner you
really are you are you're an op you are
authentic you are a crooner I'm a
crooner yep as a James Taylor as a James
Taylor fan though I don't see many James
Taylor songs is like out at a bar fun
things to say like that really brings
the mood down like that's somebody at
the bar going is this guy really singing
James Taylor yes is that the video poker
machine just contemplating all things
that are life yeah
and you're singing Carolina yeah it's
not the cocktail doesn't break out
correct this is my favorite conversation
I've ever had on television right
fantastic fun it's loose
take a 60-second break we'll come back
we'll talk more about what you guys are
up to
and then also an hour number three
Jarvis Landry of the Cleveland Browns be
joining us in Ryan Leaf in studio back
in 60 seconds with Zack Mars and Brent
Smith of chandelle Zack Mars and Brent
Smith of shine down here in studio
atencion atencion is the new album which
will hit in a second again addicted to
love is the one time you sang at karaoke
Sam Lawson randomly enough and we were
just we kind of went down a video about
how that was a that music video with the
with the models dance like pinnacle at
MTV like that was like the first like oh
my god
Rice's like yeah and then I mentioned
you Brent about a video by the police of
where sting would just knock over these
candles in the room these long candles
and you nailed yeah it was wrapped
around my finger I remember too cuz it
was all those moments where it was in
slow motion and he's like get up and up
and down and all that that you know they
didn't know you know when they were
making videos that early on that dynamic
of being on set and being in different
studios and then going on location yeah
it's pretty incredible like you hear the
song they'll sudden once that visual you
were able to connect with the song in a
totally different way we owe a lot to
MTV to be honest you still do you think
absolutely how so like what because I
think that it's a different age now for
the younger generation in regards to how
you can consume music but the fact that
it's limitless I mean there's so much
out there and but I think the visual
with the audio is still something that
can change the dynamic you know being a
musician and being a senior in a
songwriter like the two of us you know
you don't ever want to get desensitized
to your craft and you always want to be
honest and a lot of times when you're
going into a studio we always tell
people don't ever write a song because
you want to be famous write it because
it expresses who you are because an
audience is not dumb we've always said
this too we only got one boss it just
happens to be everybody in the audience
so when you bring it all the way back to
like when we were kids that visual on
top of just the hair standing up on our
arms when we heard that great song we
could
see what that artist's interpretation
was for that song with a visual so
didn't know what people look like yeah
there's another thing that was like MTV
like I was I was watching that Tom Petty
documentary and he was saying like when
it came out like it was like everyone
always knew who he was but like once the
video started coming out they were
getting recognized everywhere like
everyone in the band cuz like before
that you just had magazines and a lot of
those people didn't read magazines your
everyday common person weren't reading
hit Parader or a rolling stone or
whatever so like then it puts a face to
it
and then so everyone's out there and now
that everyone knows what you look like
yeah it's the problem was that not
everybody's face was yeah that never
needed to be seen and now they just play
Jersey Shore it's interesting too that
we're having this conversation again
Zach Mars and Brent Smith is shine down
here get up
has no video no yet yet okay it's being
filmed in three days right and yet
there's two million listens I guess you
hit three on YouTube or Spotify - okay
now I didn't know the streaming thing
that you said the 1 billion Congrats on
the banks take it I'll take that run
with it yeah so why do you think
something that does not have the visual
to it in this day and age has as many
listens on a medium that's not really
known for listening to stuff right at
your SIA videos on right - it's it's a
powerful song it's you know the album
attention attention is it's it's a story
album and get up in the story is the
shift in this individual's psychological
journey of themself
where they get their confidence back
because the whole record is built around
the fact that we don't want people to be
afraid to fail you're gonna need to fail
it's how you learn and in this world
nowadays because people are so just
consumed by what's on the internet and
everybody having an opinion and what
have you likes on Instagram
rikes yeah and also losing what's
happening with the three of us right now
which
having a conversation yeah but not doing
it like this
so the reality for that song and the the
album as well is that we don't think
that you're gonna be defined by your
failures you we think you'll be defined
by the fact that you don't give up you
know you're gonna need to fail it's it's
it's part of life but that doesn't mean
that you're going to every single time
you got to learn from it and get up is a
song also where it was written from a
very real place because the album is a
story but it's really a story about the
four of us myself sack Eric and Barry in
the band and you know Eric really put
himself really up front with this song
because you know he he has was
considered clinical depression and I
wrote the song about him and I never
ever wanted to cross a line with our
friendship but the moment that it was
written he you know I looked at him I
said you know what it's about right and
he was like it's about me and I'm like
but that's where the line was removed
and it's okay to write about it was okay
to talk about it and it was okay to to
let people know that you don't need to
be ashamed if you wake up in the morning
and you're sad you know it may not be
something that you can all the time
control and I think because of the
influx of information now in 2018 people
are so wrapped up with you know a selfie
pose or looking at themselves in the
mirror and just nitpicking everything
you've got to go back at times and take
a deep breath okay the world is gonna
keep spinning but the first person that
you have to take care of is you you'll
be the first person you see in the
morning
and your mental health is extremely
necessary and I think that the younger
generation we're watching them kind of
get just torn apart because they don't
have an opportunity to just be
themselves I got even press everybody
and that's one of the reasons why we
feel like this record is necessary right
now but with the song it is a very very
triumphant song inside of the the album
- it is the shift in this individual
where they're like all of a sudden okay
this is not necessarily gonna be easy
but I know I can do it well it's also an
important conversation to have about
mental health awareness and the stigma
that's associated right with it and how
it should not have a stigma associated
with it I mean we've had that
conversation here in May was mental
health awareness month Mauro Ranallo is
a who was calling that match that you
watched with McGregor and Mayweather man
yes he has been battling mental health
issues his entire life yeah gotta watch
that documents incredible Showtime
Sports check it out
it's incredible an hour number three
Ryan Leaf is coming in here he's gonna
be talking a little bit about Tyler
halusky was a quarterback in Washington
State who took his own life at age 21
and you just never know when somebody's
dealing with something now and it's
important to talk about it and then on
the failure front I mean this is the
stuff that was going in my head while I
was listening to tell your story also
the Super Bowl this year Nick Foles yeah
after he was done one of the most
incredible moments I've seen it a podium
after somebody who has succeeded yeah
right talked about how his failures were
the most important aspect of him being
able to succeed absolutely who's gonna
be done right like he was I mean he was
he was done yeah I mean in the odd way I
mean it wasn't done in terms of his
career but he was done in the eyes of so
many sports I mean even thought about
retiring as being yes as being somebody
who could be a super bowl-winning quia
having that ability still wet in his
body and he was out of that conversation
right no question about it
yeah and then all of a sudden he was
pressed into service and look what
happened and when he had that moment at
the podium after the game yeah and was
asked about his journey he talked about
his failures and and he I'll tell you he
made a fan out of me and he's made a fan
out of millions instantly we're talking
about just as important man falling down
is
is that's that's half of the story of
getting up okay you don't have the
getting up without the falling right and
and in that seat just a few months ago
right Chris when Scott Hamilton was here
what was the number he gave he talked
about and then seat you were sitting in
zag he said he fell down in his career
thirty thousand times yeah he was doing
the math on and he talked about his time
two years and out all the times he fell
and but do for the way he put us it he
got up thirty thousand down that's half
the story I didn't even mean the pun
when I said it in the band to like I
mean it's very very important sometimes
you have to fall in a hole to figure out
how to get out of it well check it out
attention attention and then Eve the the
singling itself that we're talking about
get up you're shooting the video in
three days yes okay do we know what what
you're shooting do is it we have a
script if storyboards yeah once again
the album attention attention is a story
and we've shot the first two videos
which was for a song called human radio
and devil which devil starts the story
this is a shifting point in the story
it's two videos were going to be doing
for two songs get up and monsters but we
have a goal by the beginning of next
year to have all of the songs filmed and
then people will be able to watch it
play out like a film okay it's too bad
to human radios over and done because
Mike del 2fo is our human radio sound
guy he's we should have put you in the
video it's too long I mean just to be
shot way more you can be in everybody on
this staff go yeah be in China yes are
talking about how everybody's taking
selfies these days and that's kind of
what staring at the fabric and we're now
making this about ourselves I don't know
where this is business I can turn
anything into a positive we're gonna get
you doing karaoke in the video not James
Taylor and here's a down and shine down
Caroline on my mind
ladies and gentleman Rich Eisen with a
rousing rendition of Carolina oh my my
well check it out the new album of
attention attention on shine down at V
Brent Smith at Z Myers official and of
course there's a dozen fan sites to
follow shinedown good to see you guys
absolutely love to do it the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience